I need a rest easy all right
hi I'm Sammy Kamkar Sammy is a privacy
researcher and computer hacker today
we're gonna talk about hackings
depiction in film and television
swordfish hacking montage in this clip
we see a pretty recurring theme in a lot
of movies that depict hacking and that's
a 3d visual interface it's not my
problem that really has nothing to do
with hacking what the is going on
in this place or is really not an
efficient interface to use at all the
more accurate interface would be a
console or terminal yeah and that's
simply because it's the most efficient
way to obtain a lot of data you can look
at a lot of code you can look a look at
a lot of text or a database and extract
the information you want very quickly
thank you Italian Job hacking traffic
lights they use video feeds from
intersections and specifically design
algorithms to predict traffic conditions
and thereby control traffic lights so
all I did was come up with my own
kick-ass algorithm to sneak in and now
we own the place see red light green
light
many of these traffic light systems are
actually controlled through systems
called SCADA systems which are
industrial controllers that allow things
like traffic lights lights working fine
just an accident in Los Angeles a number
of street lights were actually hacked
several years ago oops
and many of these traffic lights are
actually controlled over the internet
and often don't even have a password to
connect to them so totally realistic
it's good Chuck hacking into the Federal
Reserve
[Music]
in this clip we see a common theme and
that's pretty interfaces that really
have nothing to do with hacking thanks
for the help there's too much
information just coming up and down and
it's too quick for you to actually
obtain any useful information I'm sorry
we still talk to you pretty much never
see pop ups when you're doing any sort
of programming or hacking like this
Laurie in the middle of the clip they
also talk about optimizing their
compilation you know what you actually
want to pick up there at the bottom of
your page compiler can optimize a value
away like that what they're talking
about is actually optimizing something
within code and you're typically doing
compiling when you're writing some
source code and then you're compiling it
into a program or binary that you can
later run it's kind of unrelated to what
they're doing so they did take some
programming jargon and throw it in the
middle there was taken out in Skyfall
mi6 gets hacked who's using a
polymorphic engine do you take the code
I never I tried to gain access it
changes it's like solving a Rubik's Cube
that's fighting back the 3d graphics
here are similar to what you see in
swordfish there are not really
representative of anything you'd
actually see unlike swordfish there are
more realistic aspects in this clip for
one they're talking about polymorphic
code he's using a pony morphic engine do
you take the codes polymorphic code is a
program that essentially changes itself
to try to hide itself consider its our
filters will no longer work and it can
continue to spread they talk a little
bit about that in this clip never I
tried to gain access it changes they
show hex code which could be of the
virus it's just another way to represent
binary data or binary information and
that is pretty accurate however for the
purpose of the plot they do add the
grand boro boro which is not real hex
code as all hex characters are zero
through nine or A through F but they
show that for the purpose of the plot
College if hackers competing with
another hacker
unbelievable a hacker
[Music]
this clip opens with a sequence that we
would call social engineering I don't
play well with others which is
communicating with someone pretending to
be someone else and trying to extract
information that helps you break into a
machine or target computer yeah okay
besides the unrealistic visuals this is
actually something kind of common yeah
when you might hack into a machine and
you find that someone else has already
actually hacked in at this point you do
something kind of funny revenge your
goal is actually to patch the machine to
prevent any other hackers from breaking
in and you're actually helping the
target the sensitive type
but you'll often leave the back door so
that you can come back in what a back
door is a piece of software that you can
run on a machine that grants you access
in the future without the authorized
users ever knowing you're inside the
machine you're the that's been
invading my turf yeah wargames 1980s
hacking those are great yeah I don't
think that I deserved it
do you this is actually an accurate
representation of hacking back in the
1980s all right back then it was called
freaking freaking with a pH as in phone
hacking yeah in this case he's actually
dialing into a computer network over a
telephone line
dying into the schools except when you
would dial in to dial up you were
dialing into an ISP or Internet service
provider here he's actually dialing
directly into the computer that controls
the grades they changed the password
every a couple of weeks but I know where
they write it down and this is exactly
how bulletin board systems or BBS's
worked back then and a number of other
systems as well okay by accessing a
server Tron Legacy we will be making our
debut on tokyo's Nikkei index OS 12 is
the most secure operating system ever
released
many films will depict hacking as
accessing a machine and installing some
malicious software OS 12 o few bugs
however I don't really consider that
hacking
I'm just playing that in this case he's
breaking into a place physically
accessing a computer that doesn't ask
for a password that has no encryption or
has no other authorization so he simply
acts as a computer and uploading a virus
well gift hacking into a hospital mr.
robot hospitals a heavily networked one
like this are almost too easy to hack I
can make my health records look like
every other obedient zombie out there
mr. robot consistently demonstrates real
hacking and pretty reasonable scenarios
thank in this case he's hacking into a
hospital because they have pretty lack
security this is William Highsmith he is
the IT department he's also an idiot and
their technology is extremely old he's
useless security software that runs on
Windows 98 which is pretty accurate when
you're talking about most hospitals and
he's supposed to protect their network
from people like me
additionally the interfaces in this clip
are actually realistic you don't have to
worry recently we've heard of actual
hospitals getting hacked having malware
and ransomware installed and even some
parts shutting down simply due to the
lack security and old systems they never
stood a chance
NCIS stopping a hack no way I'm getting
hats or ports key it's moving too fast
our connection with the intrastate abase
separate it's too much I've never seen
cold like this stop the pop-ups this is
not good
defending against a hacker untraceable
whoever is behind the site is local and
wants attention
shut him down we are black holy nice eye
piece but every time we shut one down a
new mirror pops up the site's IP keeps
changing constantly each new address is
an exploited server this clip is
extremely accurate nice touch
a hacker has a domain name Union the
u.s. keeps taking down the IP addresses
of the domain name and the IP address is
essentially the physical address of that
domain
however the hacker has so many other IPS
or machines on the internet hacked that
he or she is able to replace them very
quickly it wasn't that wonderful
now they state that the name server and
registrar are hosted in Russia domain
register and the name servers are all in
Russian which they have no jurisdiction
over no jurisdiction there the
registrar's where you get your domain
names such as wired.com and the name
server points the domain name like wire
com2 the IP address there's a connection
there in this case the one thing they
got wrong is the US does have
jurisdiction over the dot-com good so
the US would be able to take down any
dot-com domain name how patriotic
CSI cyber clickbait the ads are
redirecting site users to what could be
a fictitious pharmacy looks like a
normal ad right and this is the code for
the ad but there's actually two codes
written right on top of each other
click begging screen right part of this
clip is someone accurate being able to
hack into a web server and modify the
code so that users who visit that site
are then affected the fake ad is masking
the legitimate app is the real thing
that happens quite common actually
however the combination of codes being
layered on top of each other it's not
really accurate it could be a
coincidence if you're viewing the source
code you're pretty much viewing
everything peekaboo
so not so realistic in this case yeah
the net disassembling a virus not to
worry everything's under control it's
gonna be okay you run into the same
theme where the interfaces themselves
are not very accurate yeah however
everything that's actually happening
here is quite accurate I appreciate it
essentially she's taking a virus and
she's disassembling it wipe out your own
system what that means is she's taking
the actual binary executable and turning
it into machine code which is the type
of code that your computer or CPU
actually executes then she's turning
into a format that she can read to see
what it's actually doing well why don't
you just tell me what this is about so
that she can help
whomever gotten hacked let them know
what has happened and how to resolve the
issue thank you this is something that
actually there are dedicated teams and
companies for today what you're kidding
right breaching the firewall castle
someone synched a rat to one of my
servers remote access to a would be
hacked their own trying to track our IP
address oh can you stop it no but I
can't slow him down one thing we see in
lot of clips is people attempt to slow
hackers down or slow something down but
really there's nothing to slow down it's
either happening or it's not we have to
stop him however there are some macros
ease here they do use a rat or no tax
exception and there are actual tools
called rats which allow you access into
machines that you otherwise shouldn't
necessarily have access to the interface
is quite inaccurate but then it also
seems that TB likes to think that
hackers send a lot of animal photos as
we've seen with the dog intron legacy
low end as we see here with lots and
lots of cats
[Music]
The Matrix Reloaded hacking into a power
grid
[Music]
in this we see some realism we see an
actual UNIX terminal and someone is
actually using a fictitious tool called
ssh nuke and what it pretty much does is
it gives them access to the power grid
it drops them into a root shell on a
UNIX machine which actually is pretty
realistic thanks and then they use
another tool SSH to log into another
machine as root which is the
administrative privilege it gives you
pretty much full access to do whatever
you want yeah you can do that
unrealistic you have the SSH nuke tool
which is not a real tool additionally
most power grids aren't on the Internet
but there's some pretty good
foreshadowing going on here as more and
more are becoming connected as it simply
makes them easier to maintain there is
nothing to stop
hacking on a cellphone Iron Man 2 and
local intelligence on the ground
indicating all of my second boy I need
him if you'll direct your attention to
shed screens I believe that South Korea
in this clip we see Tony Stark using his
mobile device to actually hack into
multiple TV screens and monitors and
it's actually kind of realistic you're
welcome as you could easily break into
say a chromecast or Apple TV and most
Smart TVs are actually internet
connected now so it's working there's a
big attack surface a lot of ways to
actually break into these TVs and cast
something that otherwise you shouldn't
weird science
stealing processing power problem is
your computers a wimp and we need a lot
more power than this that's why you see
James
[Music]
[Applause]
we have another clip with some graphical
interface that isn't very accurate I
know that but you know we can we can use
and some fun 3d visuals however the act
of breaking into a computer especially
one with more computing power and
resources than your own to try to crack
something or decrypt something is pretty
accurate today the clips we saw in
wargames and weird science take place in
the same time period however what we saw
in wargames was a lot more accurate than
what was depicted here we also get
another classic access denied' screen
yeah yeah live free or die hard
executing a virus in this clip they
don't really show actually any hacking
they do show running a virus however to
actually run a virus or upload a virus
you already must have access to the
target system thanks for that
essentially you will need to have found
a vulnerability that you can run the
virus on and only then can you actually
execute that virus Snowden surveillance
think of it as a Google search except
instead of searching only what people
make public we're also looking at
everything they don't so emails chats
SMS whatever yeah but which people the
whole kingdoms no way this is real
seriously there's actually a program
called xkeyscore that the NSA uses
execute scores under 702 Authority which
means no warrants that we actually found
out about from Snowden after he leaked a
ton of documents to the press and her
principal our government and other
governments do have the capabilities to
do this sort of thing the social network
hackathon
encryption and then intercept all
traffic of work secure of course they're
happy yes all behind a picture on you
later here's the beauty if we can find a
code written this is interesting because
it's actually rumored to be true that
Facebook would have these drinking
programming hackathons yeah although I
don't expect so many people and so much
of a party atmosphere the type of system
that he's talking about hacking into is
pretty accurate this sort of thing is
actually typical at Def Con a yearly
hacking conference in Vegas people are
hacking into each other systems
defending against other hackers and
again a lot of drinking transformers
alien hacking in this clip they're
trying to listen to a half team however
you're not actually going to be able to
do that for this type of hat no way or
hacking into a lot of computers you will
listen to sound however if you are
trying to listen to certain types of
radio frequencies and recognize what
kind of sound or modulation it might be
the direct match to the signal in Qatar
there actually was a hack recently in
Dallas where someone used radio
frequency to set off every emergency
siren in Dallas breaking encryption
under siege to see here access encoded
gigabyte of RAM to do the trick in this
clip he's attempting to break some
encryption by adding a gigabyte of RAM
you could buy two Ram to do this but
adding that gigabyte of RAM really is
not relevant to breaking the encryption
here oh you might need some significant
memory or storage space but it's not
something you'll do in the middle of
your operation really so not that
realistic
yeah blackhat NSA hacking
you asked him to change his password he
downloaded the PDF what he downloaded
was the key logger that was a pretty
long password for someone who can't
actually differentiate the difference
between a PDF file and an executable
what he downloaded was the key long
because really he downloaded something
that looked like a document but because
it was actually a key logger that means
it was a program that executed and ran
an application who really had to steal
the code that key loggers are a pretty
common way to access information from an
individual so if you want to record
their keystrokes see what their type
being honest learn passwords websites
they visit usernames and other private
information key logger is the typical
way that someone will install that on
your machine and learn that information
about you is in Jakarta Avengers 2 age
of Ultron Ultron hacking Jarvis your
intentions to be hostile at the rate of
progress with machine learning and
artificial intelligence something like
this where two different systems could
actually begin to learn about each other
communicate with each other and actually
attack each other this is rage the
visualized 3d orbs in real space are not
so accurate as insane in the future
machines will be able to think and will
have access to physical components that
they can actually move around I am a
programmer so we could see something
like this however the actual orbs of
electricity your balls of electricity
that is pretty much set in science
fiction we're out on my field to
Criminal Minds hackers competing first
we need you to look up the name Colby
Baylor this might be the coolest girl
I've ever met
but her GUI is mind-blowing
that's weird
this is also kind of similar to hackers
where two hackers were competing taking
over controller machine it was a bit
more accurate in hackers though as they
were essentially competing on the same
target system trying to prevent the
other person from accessing it in this
you see they're competing on a system
but then someone else's system actually
gets hacked what the hell so in this
case there are multiple systems getting
hacked and it's just a little bit less
realistic
this isn't good we mentioned the Linux
operating systems completely Linux based
open source programming and you don't
see this in government systems I mean
outside of like Switzerland which
actually is used in plenty of government
series there's lots of open source
software is used sort of across the
world including our government right I
get it the GUI comment is not too
accurate her GUI is mind blowing usually
when you're breaking into something
you're not actually going to run into
any GUI your graphical user interface
that's weird and even if you do it's
usually not that exciting sneakers
freakin I'm gonna bounce just call
through nine different relay stations
throughout the world and off two
satellites National Security Agency
Director of Operations please it's my
dime I'll ask the questions
it started the trace this is a cool
demonstration of freaking where they're
actually jumping not just to one other
machine over the phone who are you and
made the second leg but actually
relaying from phone to phone to phone
and you guarantee my safety freaking is
not as popular anymore as most machines
are Internet connected rather than
dial-up or phone connected we make the
call but we make it our way
algorithm hacking via email in or the
weakest link in any security systems
it's you with your shitty passwords and
how you share every part of your life
online and now I own Sam Novak's
computer in this clip they're not
showing too much of the actual hacking
but he does mention that he's exploiting
the kernel I'm just exploiting the
vulnerability her kernel access was
created this is pretty difficult to do
however there has been a recent
vulnerability in antivirus software it's
always a way in where if you received an
email with this very specific exploit it
could actually exploit the antivirus
software running in your kernel which is
essentially your operating system and
give the attacker full control of your
computer means they work for me I think
that's what they're implying here even
though they're not really showing the
actual exploit the difference does that
make to me conclusion Hollywood has the
challenge of depicting hacking which can
actually be quite a challenge because
it's not that visually stimulating
however it is always exciting when I do
see a clip that actually is realistic